hello there so today we'll be watching
some dc
trailers producer colton dredged these
up and now he wants
you to watch me watch these trailers so
we're going to do that there will be
commentary light-hearted there will be
some tears and laughter
join us on this journey just know that i
am already
previously disposed to enjoy these so
hopefully they will be good we will see
[Music]
okay so this is dark so this is batman
okay so i guess that's uh chief gordon
now that's good that's good castings
having a clue
let's play a game just me and you that's
too late already decoded it
it said he still lies do you but
actually that's what it says
hey the batsuit looks good this all
looks good
you just hope he's not a vampire that'd
suck
[Music]
why is he writing to you okay
so if i'm into this this is good
is that colin farrell that's great
makeup wow
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance i gotta say guys i'm kind
of liking what i'm seeing here
and i like the the old-school batman
mode the old-school batmobile there
that's good stuff
and the throwback shot to batman begins
with shooting the the grappling
hook to the ceiling this is this is a
good trailer it's a good trailer
i'm into it and i know people are very
down on the robert pattinson casting i'm
not
you're part of this too
am i part of it you'll see
[Music]
he's a good actor so honestly like i
know people are still down on the whole
twilight of it but
he's been a bunch of other stuff since
then and he actually can act it's just
the twilight sucks
so okay i'm into this okay i i will
watch that movie
do you think batman is going to be as
good as the dark knight no the batman
movie is not going to reach the dark
knight because christopher nolan didn't
direct it
so matt reeves directed it and he's done
some of the other robert pattinson
movies i think so he's got this kind of
dark sensibility but
he ain't no one i think it'll be kind of
gritty uh but
that's what batman is meant to be that's
fine i mean frankly i didn't i thought
ben affleck
as as batman was fine particularly
batman versus superman i thought that he
was actually quite good in batman vs
superman like justice league suck but
batman versus superman
he's actually he plays like frank
miller's batman who enjoys beating the
crap out of people
like from batman and robin all-stars so
i'm i'm kind of into
like actually the best thing in that
batman trailer is that little cutaway
where he's beating the hell out of the
criminal and then he actually stops and
then continues beating the hell out of
the criminal
because now that is very kind of in the
mode of of batman so
okay now we shall do wonder woman we'll
see if the movie's actually about chris
pine again
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
your time will come diana and everything
will be different
i'm a gal get out person okay i'm
married to an israeli
citizens of the world
i'm here to change your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have
you look it you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
well i mean same has he been dead for 50
years in the movie
like eight years right first one's world
war one
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn oh good she's a
villain and she's a communist
excellent get used to it
remember being one for rules the answer
is always more
see this also looks good you should show
me a marvel trailer if you want me to
hate watch something
forgot to tell you what radar will they
will they shoot at us
[Music]
oh yeah she turned the weird cheetah
yeah barbara
what did you do
it's not a great look for her
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
chris pine's still the best thing in the
movie it looks like what did you think
about the previous wonder woman movies i
liked the previous one rolling movie i
gave it a good review
i didn't think it was like the most
important film of all time and the
reviewers were like well it's directed
by a woman
it's patty jenkins and therefore it is
on par with citizen kane and also
it is a deeply important movie that
needs to be
historically remembered i was like well
no it's good like
it's fine uh can can i just enjoy a
movie without having to hear about how
it's
deeply historic on every possible level
because it's the first female superhero
which is not or the first female
director which it's not like
everything is historic but it was good i
mean i i enjoyed it i had i had a better
alternative ending
to the first wonder woman my better
alternative ending to the first wonder
woman
was that the bad guy is supposed to be
eric ludendorff
okay what people don't recall is that
ludendorff was actually the figure that
the nazis originally chose to unite
behind in the beer hall pooch
and so what could have been like a
really fascinating takeaway
is if she out of some bizarre sense of
mercy had let ludendorff live
and then she'd reel and then that would
have explained why she disappears for so
long
right because because she didn't take
out ludendorff that actually end leads
to the rise of hitler
and so she feels shame at that and then
she disappears because that's the big
question is why she disappears
between world war 1 and 1984 which i'm
sure they're gonna explain with
some sort of time travel thing or she
was frozen or like something they're
gonna have to explain it away but it
would have actually made mis
it would have actually made some sense
if it had been that she blew it so badly
at the end of world war one by letting
the guy go
that it led to world war ii like that
would have been like a really kind of
interesting takeaway so that was my
alternative ending there
do you think these movies will make it
to theaters when are they taught i mean
they haven't even said a release date on
this stuff right they say 2021
so by 2021 this will be in theaters for
sure i mean i think that
frankly as as soon as this is i mean
that's that's currently in production
right they've got the trailer
going uh so you assume that they'll
probably bring it out what summer 2021
sometimes so yeah i think that by by
and they didn't put a date on on wonder
woman here by by mid 2021
first of all i think that this thing may
be over in major cities like new york
and new jersey already i mean we're
still waiting to see whether there's an
uptick they haven't fully opened up
but in sweden they let this burn through
and now they're pretty much
done and that seems like the pattern and
when we talk about coven
as i've been saying when people say
there's a second wave there's no second
wave there's just a first wave in
counties that didn't have it
in northern italy there was a first wave
and then southern italy didn't get it
now southern italy is getting it
in spain madrid got it and now the other
areas of spain are getting it in the
united states
most of the south didn't get it then the
south got it illinois locked down they
prevented themselves from getting it and
now illinois is getting it
so in other words once it moves through
the community i think it kind of moves
through the community and all you can do
is sort of
protect the vulnerable and allow people
to protect themselves and go to work so
i think that by
next year vaccine or no vaccine i think
theaters will be back open and
i'm gonna go see these movies in the in
the theater i mean i'm i'm under 40. i'm
in good health and
frankly i think that this thing is going
to burn itself out mostly by next year
it's
i told you beforehand like i'm a dc guy
so i will i will watch
both of those movies and enjoy them and
jeff johns is doing an excellent job
with the direction of the dc
universe and also i'm excited to watch
the snyder cut
because joss whedon sucks
[Music]
i think it's going to surprise people
okay joel kinnaman that's good
you kind of sit there and go how did
they do that oh i like it there's nobody
that's good stuff
it's gonna be different from any
superhero movie ever made that's a
person i don't know
okay no one better in the world to
direct the suicide squad
then james gone oh that's right jim's
gone okay i saved this guy's career so
okay fine
i i accidentally ended it and then and
then uh defend him
so this one is completely unique a
person who doesn't like me but i
defended him anyway as per usual
arrangement
combined with yeah jim's going to good
he's a good director for this so
this is this is good you need your
director to set the vibe
the suicide squad is just a twisted
fantasy
of characters okay this looks fun this
does look significantly better
and uh this is sort of james gunn's
specialty right it's sort of the uh
the eclectic group movie so douchey
captain america
the guy who believes in john cena okay
yeah this'll be fun people he needs to
kill along the way
just realize guys that uh people tried
to cancel like you think you know
james gunn for the great crime of uh of
having old stupid tweets
that's our stupid world cup also if
you're a conservative he still wouldn't
be working is the way that works
everyone is exploding genitals heads
arms legs right now
okay i could go without the exploding
genitals
and no i'm not going to do a verse from
what here the biggest movie i've ever
made
i don't think that you know what to
expect okay yeah all right i'm up for
this to attach
again i feel like the dc universe has
really recovered itself here i feel like
that
marvel has kind of played out right have
we reached the end of marvel i mean
robert downey jr is gone
and so is um scarlett johansson
and so is chris evans i thought he was
always overrated but he's gone
so what exactly does the marvel universe
have left at this point i feel like dc
is gonna have a next
the next five years of dc i feel like
will be more successful than the next
five years
of marvel because they they concluded it
in the wildly overrated avengers
so thank you for watching this bizarre
video of me watching
dc stuff and hopefully next time we can
watch a video of me watching something
of people watching something like an
infinite regress of
watching not involving jerry falwell jr
all right we'll see you here next time
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button